bedtime is the safest coziest warmest
time of all
hi I am Noah MacNeil I am a puppeteer
yes it's a weird word
[Music]
this happened back in 1997 so I actually
went in that morning to audition for
another character for a game show they
were trying to develop I got a call from
Henson saying please come back because
we want you to audition for this other
character I went in and I put on what's
called the helix it's like the under
structure with the hoop rings and the
netting and this foam head and then I
realized waymond it is quarter to five
this is a courtesy you're not gonna get
this so I just said yeah forget it you
know what I'm just gonna have fun
come Monday around 6 o'clock just shy of
6 o'clock that's when I got the call
saying no like you got the part
and I was like wow it's like yeah so
that's how it happened when you're
inside you put your right arm up through
the neck and into the head and you put
your hand inside the mouth so that the
lower thumb is it's his lower jaw this
is up here and there was a little
trigger for me to do his eyebrows then
my left hand was in his left arm and
there was a tiny little string of
monofilament that went up through a
little ring in his neck he came down the
other side to the right hand which was
stuffed so whenever I moved this hand
this one would move automatically
especially when he was it was dancing
people ask how hot was it inside ice put
it in a little like thermometer one time
so it got up to like about like 92
degrees it's a dry heat and for the
season especially the first season they
would crank up the air conditioning in
the studio so it would be freezing and
people always complain about it but it
had to like you know offset the fact
that the guy in the bear suit might pass
out so they just cranked up the air
conditioning hmm
it's you ooh
Mitchell Krugman who created the show
just had it so that bear would just like
sniff the camera I came up with him
really jamming it and pulling it back
out which kids always reacted to in fact
one message I got was from a mom of a
kid who was a severely handicapped and
had not really responded even by the age
of two and she was watching the show and
as soon as bear-like jammed his nose in
the camera to sniff that's when she
jumped back and it was the first time
she actually reacted to the outside
world they were thrilled beyond measure
so yeah like sniffing can benefit the
world I've been getting lots of fan
email from the parents and from the kids
of autism and special needs who've grown
up at bear and how they said it's still
comforting for them and I realized today
there's no show
like that where it's just sincere it's
just gentle and it's just as comforting
as as bear was it's not too loud it's
not in your face
well except when he sniffs the camera so
then I've been trying to develop my show
called the show me show for kids with
autism and special needs to kind of fill
that niche because I know for a fact
that the network's the kid networks
right now aren't gonna do that so